[Music]
the air around you is in constant and
chaotic motion replete with nearly
impossible to predict swirls ranging
from large to miniscule what you're
looking at right now is a cross-section
of the flow in a typical room made
visible using a home demo involving a
laser a glass rod and a fog machine
predicting the specifics of turbulent
motion like this has long evaded
mathematicians and physicists but we are
steadily getting closer to understanding
some consistent patterns in this chaos
and in a minute I'll share with you one
specific quantitative result describing
a certain self similarity to this motion
to back up a bit
I was recently in San Diego and spent a
day with Dianna coward
aka physics girl and her frequent
collaborator Dan Walsh playing around
with vortex rings this is a really
surprising fluid flow phenomenon where a
doughnut shaped region of fluid stays
surprisingly stable as it moves through
space if you take some open container
with a lip and you fill it with smoke or
fog you can use this to actually see the
otherwise invisible ring Diana just
published a video over on her channel
showing much more of that particular
demo including a genuinely fascinating
observation about what happens when you
change the shape of the opening the
story for you and me starts when her
friend Dan had the clever idea to
visualize a slice of what's going on
with these vortex rings using a planar
laser so you know how if you shine a
laser through the fog photons will
occasionally bounce off of the particles
in the fog along that beam towards your
eye thereby revealing the beam of the
laser well Dan's thought was to refract
that light through a glass rod so that
it was relatively evenly spread across
an entire plane then the same phenomenon
would reveal the laser light along a
thin plane through that fog the result
was awesome
[Music]
the cross-section of such a smoke ring
looks like two hurricanes rotating next
to each other and this makes abundantly
clear how the surface of these rings
rotates as they travel and also how
chaotic they leave the air behind them
and as an added bonus the setup doubles
as a great Death Eater themed Halloween
decoration if you do want to try this at
home I should say be super careful with
the laser make sure not to point it near
anyone's eyes this concern is especially
relevant when the laser is spread along
a full plane basically treat it like a
gun also credit where credit is due
I'd like to point out that after we did
this we found that the channel Nighthawk
and light great channel has a video
doing a similar demo link in the
description even though our original
plan was to illuminate vortex rings I
actually think the most notable part of
this visual is how it sheds light on
what ordinary air flow in a room looks
like in all of its intricacy in detail
we call this chaotic flow turbulence and
just as vortex rings give an example of
unexpected order in the otherwise messy
world of fluid dynamics I'd like to
share with you a more subtle instance of
order amidst chaos in the math of
turbulence first off what exactly is
turbulence the term is familiar to many
of us as that annoying thing that makes
plane rides bumpy but nailing down a
specific definition is a little tricky
it's easiest to describe qualitatively
turbulence involves many swirling
Eddie's it's chaotic and it mixes things
together one approach here would be to
describe turbulence based on what it's
not laminar flow this term stems from
the same Latin word that lamination does
lamina meaning a thin layer of a
material and it refers to smooth flow in
a fluid where the moving particles stay
largely confined to distinct layers
turbulence in contrast contains many
Eddie's points of some vorticity also
known as positive curl also known as a
heist whirly swirly factor breaking down
the notion of distinct layers
however vorticity does not necessarily
imply that a flow is turbulent
patterns like whirlpools or even smoke
rings have high vorticity since the
fluid is rotating but can nevertheless
be smooth and predictable instead
turbulence is further characterized as
being chaotic meaning small changes to
the initial conditions result in large
changes to the ensuing patterns it's
also diffusive in the sense of mixing
together different parts of the fluid
and also diffusing the energy and the
momentum from isolated parts of the
fluid to the rest notice how in this
clip over time the image shifts from
having a crisp delineation between fog
and air to instead being a murky mixture
of both of them as to something more
mathematically precise
there's not really a single widely
agreed upon clear-cut criterion the way
that there is for most other terms in
math the intricacy of the patterns
you're seeing is mirrored by a
difficulty to parse the physics
describing all of this and that can make
the notion of a rigorous definition
somewhat slippery you see the
fundamental equations describing fluid
dynamics the navier-stokes equations are
famously challenging to understand we
won't go through the full details here
but if you're curious the main equation
is essentially a form of Newton's second
law that the acceleration of a body
times its mass equals the sum of the
forces acting on it
it's just that writing mass times
acceleration looks a bit more
complicated in this context and the
force is broken down into the different
types of forces acting on a fluid which
again can look a bit intimidating in the
context of continuum dynamics not only
are these hard to solve in the sense of
feeding in some initial state of a fluid
and figuring out how the equations
predict that fluid will evolve
there are several unsolved problems
around a much more modest task of
understanding whether or not
quote-unquote reasonable solutions will
always exist
reasonable here means things like not
blowing up to a point of having infinite
kinetic energy and the smooth initial
States yield smooth solutions where the
word smooth carries with it a very
precise meaning in this context the
questions formalizing the idea of these
equations predicting reasonable behavior
actually have a 1 million dollar prize
associated with them
and all of that is just for the case of
incompressible fluid flow where
something compressible like air makes
things trickier still and the heart of
the difficulty both for the specific
solutions and the general theoretical
results surrounding them is that tricky
to pin down phenomenon of turbulence but
we're not completely in the dark the
hard work of a lot of smart people
throughout history has led us to
understanding some of the patterns
underlying this chaos and I'd like to
share with you one found by the 19th
century mathematician Andrey Kolmogorov
it has to do with how kinetic energy in
turbulent motion is distributed at
different length scales in simpler to
think about physics we often think about
kinetic energy at two different length
scales a macro scale say the energy
carried by your moving car or a
molecular scale which we call heat as
you apply your brakes energy is
transferred more or less directly from
that macro scale motion to the molecular
scale motion as your brakes and the
surrounding air heats up meaning all of
their molecules start jiggling even
faster turbulence on the other hand is
characterized by kinetic energy at a
whole spectrum of length scales from the
movement of large Eddie's to smaller
ones and smaller ones and smaller ones
still moreover this energy tends to
cascade down the spectrum where what I
mean by that is that the energy of large
Eddie's gets converted into that of
smaller Eddie's which in turn bring
about smaller Eddie's still this goes on
until it's small enough that the energy
dissipates directly to heat in the fluid
which is to say molecular scale jiggling
due to the fluids viscosity which is to
say how much the particles tug at each
other or as this was all phrased in a
poem by Lewis F vitchard s'en big whirls
have little whirls which feed on their
velocity and little whirls have lesser
whirls and so onto viscosity now you
might wonder whether more of the kinetic
energy of this fluid is carried by all
of the larger Eddie's say all those with
diameter one meter
or by all of the smaller ones say all
those with diameter 1 centimeter counted
together or more generally if you were
to look at all of the swirls with a
diameter D about how much of the fluids
total energy do they collectively carry
is that even an answerable question
Camus Gaurav hypothesized that the
amount of energy in a turbulent flow
carried by eddies with diameter D tends
to be proportional to D to the power 5/3
at least within a specific range of
length scales known fancifully as the
inertial subrange for air this ranges
from about zero point one centimeters up
to one kilometer this fact has since
been verified by experiment many times
over it would appear that 5/3 is a sort
of fundamental constant of turbulence
it's an oddly specific fact I know but
what I love about the existence of a
constant like this is that it suggests
there's some predictability however
slight to this whole mess there is
something ironic about talking about
this energy cascade while viewing
two-dimensional slices of a fluid
because it is a distinctly
three-dimensional phenomenon while fluid
flow in two dimensions can have a sort
of turbulence this energy transfer
actually tends to go the other way from
the small scales up to larger ones so
keep in mind while you're looking at
this 2d slice of turbulence it's
actually very different in character
from turbulence in 2d
one of the mechanisms behind this energy
cascade which could only ever happen in
three dimensions is a process known as
vortex stretching a rotating part of the
fluid will tend to stretch out
perpendicular to the plane of rotation
resulting in smaller Eddie's spinning
faster this transition from energy held
in a large vortex to instead being held
in smaller vortices would be impossible
if there weren't another dimension to
stretch in or if this vortex were bent
around to meet itself in a ring shape in
a way it's like a vortex which is
blocking itself from stretching out this
way and as mentioned earlier this is
indeed a surprisingly stable
configuration for a fluid order amidst
chaos interestingly though when we made
these vortex rings in practice and
followed them over a long period of time
they do have a tendency to slowly
stretch out I'll be it at a much longer
time scale than the vortex stretching I
was just talking about which brings us
back to Diana and Dan huge thanks to the
both of them for getting so much footage
and making all of this happen make sure
to hop over to physics girl now to see
some of the vortex ring demos and as I
said you'll also get to learn about
something that happens when you change
the shape of the hole in this vortex
cannon the result then it's specific
certainly surprised me and you'll get to
hear it through Diana's
typical and infectious superhuman level
of enthusiasm
[Music]